what we want to do in this video is get
an understanding of how we can
approximate the area under a curve and
for the sake of an example we'll use the
curve y is equal to x squared plus 1.
and let's think about the area under
this curve above the x-axis from x
equals negative one to x equals two
so that would be
this area right over here
and there's many ways that i could
tackle this but what i'm going to do is
i'm going to break up this interval into
three equal sections that are really the
bases of rectangles and we're going to
think about the different ways to define
the heights of those rectangles
so once again i'm going to approximate
using
three rectangles
of
equal
width
and then we'll think about the different
ways that we can define the heights of
the rectangles so let's first define the
height of each rectangle by the value of
the function at the midpoint so we see
that right over here and so let's just
make sure that it actually makes sense
to us
so
if we look at our first rectangle right
over here actually let's just first
appreciate we have split up this x for
the we've split up the interval from x
equals negative one to x equals two into
three equal sections and then each of
them have a width of 1. if we wanted a
better approximation we could do more
sections or more rectangles let's just
see how we would compute this
well the width of each of these is one
the height is based on the value of the
function at the midpoint the midpoint
here is negative one-half the midpoint
here is one-half the midpoint here is
three-halves
and so this height is going to be
negative one-half squared plus one so
negative one-half squared is one-fourth
plus one so that's five-fourths so the
height here is five-fourths so you take
five-fourths times one this area is
five-fourths let me write that down so
if we're doing the midpoint
to define the height of each rectangle
this first one has
an area of five-fourths let me do that
in a color you can see
five over four the second one same idea
one-half
squared plus 1 is 5 4 times the width of
1.
so 5 4 there so let me add that
plus
5 4.
and then this third rectangle what's its
height
well we're going to take the height at
the midpoint so three halves squared is
nine fourths plus one
which is the same thing as 13 fourths so
it has a height of 13 fourths and then a
width of one so times one which would
just give us thirteen
fourths
so
plus
thirteen fourths which would give us 23
over four which is the same thing as
five
and 4. and so this is often known as a
midpoint approximation where we're using
the midpoint of each interval to define
the height of our rectangle but this
isn't the only way to do it we could
look at the left endpoint or the right
endpoint and we do that in other videos
and if we want to do it just for kicks
here let's just do that really fast
so if we want to look at the left
endpoint of our interval
well here are
left endpoint
is negative 1. negative 1 squared plus 1
is 2
2 times 1
gives us 2
and then here
the left part of this interval is x
equals zero zero squared plus one is one
one times one is one
and now here
our left endpoint is one
one squared plus one is equal to two
times one our base is equal to two
so here we have a situation where we
take our left endpoints
where it is equal to
two plus one plus two or five but we
could also look at the right endpoints
of our intervals
so this first rectangle here clearly
under approximating the area over this
first interval its right endpoint is
zero zero squared plus one is one so
height of one width of one has an area
of one second rectangle here
it has a height of we look at our right
endpoint one squared plus one is two
times our width of one well that's just
going to give us 2
and then here our right endpoint is 2
squared plus 1 is 5
times our width of 1 gives us 5. so in
this case we get when we look at our
right endpoints of our intervals we get
plus 2 plus 5 is equal to 8. and
eyeballing this it looks like we're
definitely over counting more than under
counting and so this looks like an over
approximation so the whole idea here is
just to appreciate how we can compute
these approximations using rectangles
and as you can imagine if we added more
rectangles that had skinnier and
skinnier bases but still covered the
interval from x equals negative 1 to x
equals 2 we would get better and better
approximations of the true area